هذه المدينه بحسب المعلومات التي حصلنا
عليها سيتم هدها بشكل كامل والانتقال الى
خطه جديده من اجل ايواء مواطنيها
السيناريو الابرز هو بناء بيوت وخيم
وايجاد خيم وحاويات معدنيه لكن في هذه
المنطقه التي نقف فيها ربما يكون هناك
اجابه للسؤال حول كيف ستكون المرحله
المقبله في هذا المكان هذه الشركه المحليه
بدات في بناء بيوت هذه البيوت من طابق
واحد وهي من الطوب وهي تبني على مساحه
تقدر بحوالي هنا في هذا المشروع على الاقل
اتحدث مساحه تقدر ب 200 واربعين الف متر
يعني 240 دونم وهذا المشروع ليس وحده هناك
مشروع اخر في منطقه مجاوره مجموع هذه
المساحه في هذه المنطقه فقط يزيد على
400 الف متر مربع هذه البيوت هنا من طابق
واحد الان تجري عمليه البناء سيسلم هذا
المشروع بحسب مسؤوليه الشركه الذين تحدثت
اليهم قبل هذه المقابله يفترض ان يسلم 525
منزلا من هذه البيوت حتى نهايه الشهر
الحالي اي خلال اسبوعين وهذه البيوت ستكون
مجهزه بشكل كامل ليس فقط البناء ستكون
مجهزه بما يحتاج تحتاج هذه البيوت في
داخلها لتكون جاهزه للسكن وذلك خلال 15
يوما القسم الثاني من المشروع سيكون في
مرحله لاحقه نلاحظ ان هنا عملي استمرار
عمليات البناء لتسليم هذا المشروع في فتره
زمنيه سريعه طبعا هذا المشروع ليس وحده
هنا في هذا المكان هناك عده مشاريع مشابهه
في مناطق اخرى المساحات التي نتحدث عنها
تزيد ربما عن
مئات الدونمات وهذه المساحه هي اراضي
خصصتها الدوله من اجل بناء بيوتا كهذه
هذه البيوت
هذه البيوت ستكون خيارا ربما مبدئيا من
اجل اسكان المواطنين الاتراك الذين هم
موجودون في تضررت بيوتهم في مدينه نوردا
لان هذه المدينه سيتم حجمها بالكامل ومن
ثم دراسه ارضها من جديد لمعرفه ما اذا
كانت ستكون صالحه للبناء مجددا ام لا